to my right is bounty law series lead
and jake cahill himself rick dalton and
to my left is rick stutt devil cliff
booth
so rick uh explain to the audience
exactly what it is a stunt double does
actors are required to do a lot of
dangerous stuff
[Music]
cliff here is meant to help carry the
load is that uh how you describe your
job cliff well carrying his load
yeah it's about right
[Music]
my hands are registered as lethal
weapons
we get into a fight i accidentally kill
you
i go to jail
anybody accidentally kills anybody in a
fight they go to jail it's called
manslaughter
[Music]
[Music]
that was the best acting i've ever seen
in my whole life
like you
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
academy visiting artists film series
filmmate edition for casting directors
i'm bernie telsey casting director and
i'm here today with my good friend
fellow casting director vicky thomas
how are you today vicki
hi there how are you bernie
i'm good i feel like i wish i wasn't in
new york so far away from you so we
could do it in person i know well you
know how are you well it is i'm good i'm
good i'm looking forward to a very long
long weekend so yes exactly yes exactly
uh well we're here today to talk about
what it is that you and i do every day
and for all these wonderful film
students so i'd love to start with just
saying how did you get into casting and
then how did you transition into having
your own business
well i didn't get into casting via the
usual route i never
worked for anyone it was really just
me working with a fellow film student at
ucla
and they asked me to cast their student
thesis film and not okay
um
you know we would always work on each
other's films whether we were you know
making lunch for the crew or holding a
boom mic or you know everybody just kind
of pitched in and helped each other
and i think someone said well maybe you
think you should cast that and okay they
asked me and i said okay sure and uh
that student thesis film evolved over
the course of a year
and became a low-budget independent
movie called repo man
and they just kept me on when the film
actually became like a legitimate
movie
and um yeah i just sort of
got thrown into the deep end of the pool
and uh
tried to learn what it meant to be a
casting director or how you cast a film
so i didn't i didn't have the privilege
of really of working for
for someone uh sort of being taught the
ropes and
you know coming up through the ranks
right i would have really
enjoyed you know i just kind of i got
thrown in i just had to learn how to
swim
and then do you remember this sort of
time when you woke up one day and said
oh i'm going to do this for a living
and i'm going to do this for my
profession
yeah it's funny because i did that and i
went oh that's just sort of a one-off
and then i think i wouldn't work a
couple other jobs or whatever and then i
came back and uh the same producer of
the film asked me to help him out in
another movie
and then i got a call
that didn't happen then i got a call
from ed pressman's office
you know someone who actually didn't
know me
you know so a friend was giving me a job
and they wanted to hire me to be their
casting consultant okay and to cast a
movie with david byrne
oh
okay sure you know and i went in my
little meeting i made my little notes
and had my little
suggestions and uh yeah i think after
that i went oh i guess i could put
something
in that occupation slot or whatever
piece of paper you fill out and it was
right around then went oh i guess
casting director
right
that's great
what do you love about casting and what
are some of your guiding principles when
you start casting a film
i think i love i think like a lot of
casting directors i love working with
the actors just getting in a room and
right it's like let's run the scene
and you know let's try try something
different
i think just the actual process of
auditioning actors which has been
a little hampered by
obviously the covet times where we're
living in
but that's really the best for me and
just seeing someone kind of
flower
you know you can form and sort of come
alive in an audition audition room and
look i guess like all casting directors
you obviously want to cast you know the
best
the perfect person for the part um
you're the best actor you can and
hopefully
make some sort of surprising choice
along the way and hopefully maybe break
someone you know um yeah that's the best
well yeah that's really the exciting uh
the exciting part of it so yeah i mean
do you have any principles i mean just
in terms of
what do you know
i don't know one of my biggest
principles is just
being nice and being
you know available to
all of the different kinds of people
that we work with whether it be the
actor director you know it's such a
personality business yes yes learning
how to be that host
so to speak of like you know how to
engage with each person whether we agree
or don't agree
yeah and everybody's got a different
yeah so they're a lot of different
personalities and uh
yes it's like surfing it's like sort of
like you know
just
because you yeah there's never one one
experience or one
right one type of you know personality
or one you know that's just they're all
different so you kind of have to
be able to adjust
can you share a little bit about it's
day one and you're about to work on this
new movie and you've read it
what are those early first conversations
like with you and a director
well usually i i
i like to have conversations words not
just about the casting it's sort of the
overall
feel of the movie the overall
story
um
just sort of what we're trying to
achieve and how casting can help that
um so i think it helps to be brought
along um
as a casting director
and end of the the filmmaking process
you know just as a fellow filmmaker
because we're all hopefully trying to go
for the same goal and
and uh yeah i just think a sense of the
overall picture
you know um
and yeah and then you obviously you get
into you know the casting you get into
characters and get into i like
conversations where there's sort of
well who would this character have been
in the 50s you know what actor would
have played this role
you know if we were casting this in the
50s or the same like that like that you
know because that actually kind of
uh that surprisingly gives me a real
good sense of oh it's okay let's uh
well it's a nice way to start because it
takes you
out of talking about someone in the
moment you know what i mean it's like
you know well it kind of allows you to
sort of it helps in free associating it
helps in kind of getting out of
a sort of uh
such a
maybe a closed-off sort of uh
mentality about
the current actors of today or whatever
you know so it's just it's just sort of
freeing a little bit yeah
and it's
yeah
you bring up a good point because so
much of the relationship between a
casting
director and the director is the
collaboration in the give-and-take as
you were saying but
what are some of the what do you do
when you do come up against that
you know
conversation about a present actor that
you particularly might be passionate
about and the director he or she
is not
how do you
help change a mind potentially or
what do you do when you come across that
stumbling block no you started maybe
plant a seed
you know you put a picture over there
and you know
leave it alone
come back a few days ago huh you know
maybe that no no no no we don't want
that okay okay well let's just go on and
keep moving we'll keep reading people
and it just this actually just happened
recently um
no definitely not they're definitely
okay well let's just keep going
you know let's keep reading people and
try to find what you're really looking
for that fits your
you know you keep going you go you know
what that guy that actor that
you want to look at him again you know
so you just kind of plant a seed sort of
bring it back uh
and usually through the process of
casting
something may open up for the director
as well if you sort of are going for
something so specific
that it's sort of
you're not quite finding it and then you
might find actually what you're looking
for
with an actor that you didn't expect
to get that from um
actually actually what you're talking
about for this character this actor
actually brings to you in a slightly
different way but
you know
that might work just as well if not
better
right
right
uh
do you find the conversations
that are happening today
[Music]
based on the recent racial justice
movement that we've all been part of in
the last two years
are those conversations been easier
harder to have with creative team
members about inclusion and belonging
and diversity as far as where it relates
to
actors well easier and harder because
look yes let's find roles for actors of
all races let's like reflect a world as
it exists and if that happens to be a
multiracial world
right but also if it's like you know
if we're doing a film about the amish
and then i don't really want to shoehorn
a actor of color into necessarily a film
about
the amish and you have to be careful
sometimes i
you know i don't want to just
i want the best best actor for the part
and i don't want tokenism
um
so how do you it's it's it's it's just
it can get a little tricky the
conversations where it's like well it
has to be this there has to be that it
starts to look like a
like sort of a benetton ad or something
that's just being put on not in a
natural
organic way so that sometimes
those are tricky conversations because i
think i find myself
you know sometimes as the only black
woman in the room you know arguing for
the white actor to play that particular
part
right
it just well i just think well that it
just seems to fit that role
better
and achieve what you're trying to
achieve if that character
is a white actor you know what i'm
saying i know we're all inclined to
be inclusive but just want to make sure
it's not getting in the way of
what you're trying to do with the film
or the television projects that make
sense yeah no no i feel like
you know for me it's been a little
it's been enlightening and i don't want
to see easier isn't the right word but
now i feel like on day one the teams are
are wanting us to lead those
conversations i mean i know i know you
and i have been
you know seeing diverse actors since the
day we started in casting because why
wouldn't you yeah you know it was always
better to play with a bigger crayon box
of actors
but then the decision-making is what
always didn't happen until the end and
then it was too late to have those
conversations about why can it be
and now i find
like it's like the first day of school i
walk in and
yes let's talk about what this role is
and what does it really mean and why can
it be or why can't it be yeah
and
i find that i think
these conversations don't aren't being
led by us anymore i think the
conversations are being led by
the studios they're being led by
some producers or they're being led by
the network or what you know they're
it's like it's definitely been in the
last
i don't know bernie what do you think
three
yeah
four years just
we don't have to like encourage anybody
right now it's reminding you know and
yeah you know but
uh
and then let's talk about
that challenge what what do you do when
you're faced against the challenge of
the bankable actor
that will bring the financing to an
independent film or a studio film versus
who might be better suited creatively i
mean how do you handle those
conversations
well i mean it's kind of a reality we
have to deal with and then it's and i
understand
someone is putting up a lot of money
for a film they like to
get at least some sense they're going to
get their money back and maybe make some
money so i i understand that you know i
think all of that isn't always
guaranteed but i it's it's just
i understand
people wanting that comfort you know so
you just
try to
maybe balance
the known then give them the the well
this is the unknown version this is the
the known version and if something
happens maybe
you get your lead in this role and maybe
you can slip in someone less known who's
great
in this other this other role but i mean
it's just a reality of the business that
we
we work and on some projects it's a lot
more
like no we need
you know
that and you we need
uh
it's not like a chinese menu but it's
just like
you know they want bankable people in
all these roles if it's a big franchise
movie they want yeah
they want
that's what they want
yeah and that you just have to sort of
deal with that and like i said maybe try
to slip in something a little surprising
along the way in some of the other parts
but
you know it's a reality we have to deal
with right right
uh you've worked on a
bunch of films by the same director
or producer and uh can you talk a little
bit specifically about
what those collaborations and
relationships are like and what they
were like from the first time you worked
with
he or she
versus now the fifth time or
you know and what those
and how your relationship between a
casting director and director grows and
changes
i guess uh maybe you develop
a little more of a shorthand as you work
with people more and more um
and
you know with
like with ed's wic it's like he's like
my brother it's like we argue a lot
in a great sort of
joking way but we we i think feel
familiar enough with each other to like
get on each other's nerves
uh
and be fine with the fact that we're
getting on each other's nerves that's
gonna be okay and i'm not gonna be
thrown out of the
out of the room or something um
with someone like quentin it's just we
had a short hand immediately
uh just because we had similar cultural
references similar
film references similar
memories of
television shows we looked at and so we
had we got we got along very very
quickly right right um
and is it different now working with
quentin that it was
just as more just more
we just laugh a lot we laugh a lot more
and you know just right
uh
it's
more relaxed more comfortable just you
know more intimate in in a way and
but it was pretty close from the from
from the get-go
and you know look sometimes you have
relationships with directors bernie and
you work with them and sometimes
you know people feel like they want to
just try something different or
you know just you know
and and it could you know you kind of
you have to watch that you don't sort of
take it personally or
you know get hurt but sometimes those
three films you did with someone they
want to go and do something else with
somebody else and it's you just have to
learn how to navigate that emotionally
you know but um
that comes with age right i think it
comes
yes
yes yeah so it's uh that's a little
tricky too because yeah you don't
sometimes you don't do the five movies
together sometimes you do the two or
sometimes you do one right
the three but yeah yeah
but what i
something i find when you do when you
are lucky enough to repeat and totally i
agree with you you understand they work
with different actors they work with
different
designers in locations why not a
different casting director but
when we are lucky enough to repeat
there's such a sense of
you know it's such a hard process
falling in love with actors and making
that final decision
yeah you know yes that's who i'm going
to put in my movie i mean we know
they're always that's always the most
vulnerable for the directors when they
finally have to commit it's so nice when
you have that trust
with as a casting director with that
director that like you said shorthand or
when you can go
oh i know that your taste i know what
you like yeah trust me about this actor
more than you may or may be seeing right
now in this audition and
i love when trust is there
yeah and it's okay to actually for them
to ask for them to say okay
really do you think i mean for them to
really kind of look at you and go
believe that they can do it they can do
it yeah you know so that's uh
yeah they're vulnerable yeah they're
sure because they've got a lot on the
line
too
you know just trying to they don't want
to make a mistake and casting i think is
a huge part of
the success
of a movie creatively
especially creatively you know so
yeah and i've also
found the more we do this right it's
always
it's really one of the first
things
that the director
is doing is committing to is
actively doing
you know what i mean and yet
they're finding their way no matter how
much personal prep they might have done
so
it's a little bit like
i know they're not consciously thinking
this but i always think it's like well
if we make a decision of who we're going
to cast
then we're going to have to actually go
to the next step which is start making
the movie
exactly which is scary yes yeah
yeah
i actually had a director
we we started cast in the movie they
were scared because they were jumping
into some controversial territory and
i'd gone to new york uh and they were
going to come and meet me to meet a
couple of actors and
he called me says i can't i can't do it
i can't he he wasn't he wasn't ready yet
and i went it's okay i i think i kind of
got it i knew that there's some
it wasn't prima donna behavior it was
just
i said that's okay we're gonna we'll
just figure this out later i'll tell
these people you'll meet them at another
time
you know but they were really yeah in
terms of that vulnerability of of a
director
you know making those casting decisions
i mean you're right now you're committed
you're in the movie
you're you're making it
right and that was yeah that was
interesting it was
it was a lesson in empathy you know i
mean
[Music]
yeah
so yeah
talk a little bit about what you look
for
in an audition what are the nuances or
what makes a great
audition for you for you know when you
see an actor
um
how would you answer that question
bernie can i answer
you know i i always you know obviously
we have a sense of
what we believe the
you know
what the director is looking for we know
what their vision is so we have that
sense of do they fit what it is that
we've been told
but i think for me it's someone that
just walks into that room and makes me
feel something in whatever short time
i'm in the room i mean it's i know that
sounds corny for me but it's
it's like oh did i feel something having
heard this 65 times or two times was
there something that made me
because i feel like i'm always racing
like i know what we need i know what
you're not
yeah but it's like it feels like all
time stops for that half a second
because of something that the actor was
doing and they
and they just moved me and
yeah i think
maybe people don't realize that what we
do is we may hear something 62 times or
would read a scene
and nothing rises above
it's just all sort of like this
and you're right at that moment when
someone comes in and gives it
yeah it makes you feel something or
actually makes the dialogue work in a
different way than anybody else had it's
like that is that moment that sort of
aha
moment or uh
yeah the moment that makes you go oh
[ __ ]
i think uh i think we this part is
actually going to work and there's
somebody who can actually play this part
even though i've looked at a hundred
other people and you've gotten depressed
because it nothing seems to be working
and have anybody getting a bad reading
it's not that they're all like bad
not at all it's just that nothing is
sort of
rising above
and yeah when someone comes in and it's
like oh shoot oh oh that's it
yeah it's exciting very exciting and i
don't think you can kind of define the
nuance exactly right
right absolutely it depends on each
particular part
what are some of the places
that you look for new talent or
was there a specific role of a movie you
were working on
where you you know had to go out of the
box to find someone that would be a fun
thing for the students to hear about
of you know like that detective thomas
you know like where you had to go
outside of the norm to maybe find
someone
or just generally where do you like to
look for new talent
yeah just wherever wherever it may be i
did a movie called a family thing
years ago with robert duvall and uh
we were looking for an older black woman
to play a role like the lead role of
black nature
and i'd been in texas years before
working on a film
and i met this woman irma p hall and she
just seemed to be great and she just you
know was mainly in texas and
did you know parts in movies that were
based in in texas and
uh
that hadn't really
done anything big outside of
films that were shooting there
and we lost an actress
that was going to play this part someone
more famous appropriate or whatever and
that's her way
and i just went i'm my p hall she's in
dallas texas she's like donald played so
whatever
and um
i'm gonna turn she came in and booked it
and so i guess that's an example maybe
you just
not necessarily someone from outside a
box but sure sure
you know
someone who wouldn't have normally
gotten that part
yeah that's the
right sure and um
but i mean look i think it also it
depends what sort of movies we're doing
bernie in terms of uh
how much you're able to go outside of a
box in a certain way there's some films
that lend themselves to you know you
have to find a
short you know a little person whatever
whatever the specific little
yeah
it's all the same you put on the
detective hat and you start looking yeah
and it's fun to enter that world yeah
i'm looking for a deaf kid right now
you know
and it's just like uh it's fun to sort
of be an explorer in that world and
really try to find
whether it's through deaf societies or
wherever um
find someone who could who could who
could make that could do that part so
um i'll try to figure out a story of
someone
outside the box of cats before that's
all right are there
any
well-known actors today
but when they weren't well known or when
they were just starting out in the
business
that they came in and auditioned for you
for a certain project but then you
now watched years later oh my god now
they're an oscar nominee you know are
there any sort of
you know
you know don cheadle who who came in i
think like in 80
late 80s he played a soda fountain jerk
and then low budget movie for me oh my
god
it yeah yeah when he first started
thinking he was at cal arts but he just
started he did a day
soda fountain jerk
uh
you know um
uh
imagine remember
like catherine keener just auditioning
all the time and never getting apart
you know but you would always bring her
in years later she said we said i think
i just want to thank you for always
bringing me in i never got anything i
just want to thank you for bringing me
back
uh
but you figure these people you know
bernie they're good
you bring them back in something's gonna
hit you know
um but yeah i think don is a soda
fountain jerk i mean look
gary oldman was cass and sid and nancy
was we had london in us casting he was
casting he was cast out of london and i
remember seeing him for the first time
arriving
at jfk in new york to start work on sid
nancy and there's this like this little
guy leaning against the wall
and the most unassuming
guy and and there's like
that that's i mean you would never guess
he would be girls i mean he was just
very unassuming his first big role
and um
yeah he became
what he
okay i mean viggo you know was used to
hang out with vigo
santa monica would do like a small part
in a movie called roadside prophets and
you know it's
i don't know you see them sort of take
off
the vego story reminds me of i was
casting a off-broadway production for
evo von hove
who's a wonderful
uh european director but he was doing
his version of streetcar
and
this was way before he was doing movies
but viggo came in
and it was like you know new york guy
and it was like oh my god the most
amazing stanley audition
wow and then we offer it to him and then
of course like in the next minute one of
you la casting directors sat him up
and he became a movie star and i don't
think he even has never been back to the
stage
but it was like damn
but it happens you know we all watch it
happen it's so great when it happens he
really is and he was
the reluctant movie star he was
marches to his own drumbeat
you know this was sort of a jerry
brookheimer commercial
movie
you know you know it's and you're trying
to you know now come on in and do it
it's like conair john cuzak and steve
buscemi were all independent film guys
and you say oh well come on for this
jerry brookheimer see that you know they
they had a certain edit i love jerry
he's a great producer but had a certain
sort of hollywood commercial
sheen that they
were not usually in and uh
to watch them sort of do one of those
movies and actually like come out the
better for it i mean it helped
them continue to do the independent
things they wanted to do and also do
open up maybe an audience for them so
how have you felt in these in the last
few i was going to say months but it's
really i guess almost two years
casting virtually how is that
affected what are the pros and the cons
well the pros are you can see many more
people i know shorter amount of time
so that's kind of great but i and from
anywhere
from anywhere and you also sort of see a
certain sort of screen
magnitude yeah magnetism is maybe the
the wrong word
but just somebody is somebody able to
hold the screen a little bit
then you know look it's it's been
frustrating for directors at work but
they want to be in a room with an actor
and see them in the flesh and work with
them and so in that sense i miss the
other thing but i don't think it's going
to go back
just because there is a convenience to
it that's my fear
i mean it's gone back
in the theater i do some theater of
course and yeah that's been in person
yeah
but i do feel like
the film and tv was already leaning
towards
you know
not in person that now
the convenience
for some or outweighing
yeah
yeah
i i i miss being in the room with actors
live
so much
yeah i've done a few in in-person things
it's usually such a
such a bit you know to do with a test
and thing and better the bed but um it's
just really good to be in a room with it
but i realize it's just not going to go
back completely the way it was so
we just have to put singing in every
movie because that's been our way
like we're doing the wicked film but
because we're doing the musicals it's
like we have to do them in person
you can't sing virtually so it's like
that's not telling everyone what a song
yeah
so most of your theater things are
you're you're you're doing a curtain
yeah i mean the pre-screens are on
virtual yeah yeah one of us
but the themes the things with the teams
are all in person
i remember before before uh we shut down
like a couple weeks before we shut down
someone was saying to me well you know
so-and-so does all their
pre-reads
you know with self tapes and then
they pick from those who they want to
come and greet in person what really
went oh huh that's kind of good because
i would do all the pre-screens i would
me too
i would do them all and i was going but
something in my head went oh that's kind
of great
and little did i know that that was what
was going to be sort of forced on us in
the next
the next uh few months so
yeah
uh before we get into some of the
questions
from our filmmate students in kenya i
would love to ask the question of what
would you tell someone who said
i want to go into casting and they're
just getting out of school
and whether there's a job or not
what would you say to someone who's
interested in casting
um i think i would sort of encourage it
and uh
i would
i would want to know
why
[Laughter]
you know don't ask me why
really first of all
um
i
you know our job is a little like you
know psychologists it's it's it's
recognizing talent it's
it's a lot of different components and
uh
um as long as people are sort of ready
for that i sometimes i'm not sure people
really know what being in casting means
right sure
um
so i'd probably ask them what they
thought it was what they like what they
think they might like about it
and uh
hopefully encourage
encourage someone who really seem to
have a passion for actors
um
[Music]
yeah but i think i i don't think it's a
closed off
i don't think it's a closed-off uh
job
you know and i i think there's so much
i said a young person they can do
now before even having that job
you know they live in the world of the
internet you know start taking notes of
every film or tv or theater thing that
they saw yeah yeah to
hone in on their taste
you know like
well what is taste it's like well go see
something and start
talking out loud or talking to yourself
about what you thought of those
performances
and who stood out
even if it was the you know the one line
part and i i often tell i think of a
sense of
film history
and
theater history you know just
the great performances the great actors
i always tell actors just go
look at great actors whether they're
from the
you know the 90s the 80s the 60s the 50s
the 40s are great
actors i said adopt an actor and just
look at all their movies
and sort of get to know
what great screen acting could could
could be like
um i love that adopt an actor it's a
great one
it's a great one yeah and
you know i love that suggestion too of
watching it in order
yes i mean and you see i mean a friend
of mine did it yes it sounded like fun
they watched every merrell street movie
from the first one to the last
but they really came at it from a sense
of watching the growth i mean yes you
brilliant on day one but yes it's just
that's a really great way to learn
exactly by watching how they change how
they grow
exactly
exactly exactly yeah
no i think it's a great profession and i
feel like our profession has gotten more
visibility more recognition yeah and
it's a place to make a living you know
that it is
and i think it's i think it's i mean i
really do think it's one of
i think it's all creative positions on
on the making of a film or a theater
piece you know
but it's
you really can impact
something
right
um
and and in a big way
and that's nerve-wracking too i get i i
feel the burden
in a way and i just said oh my god what
are we going to do you know but it's so
you can really have an impact
right
i'm going to ask some of the we had some
really good questions from our
uh kenya filmmade students if if you
have a few extra minutes
uh great uh
how long does it take you to cast or get
the right actor in the right role
how much time do you have is the
question right we worked on something
for three months and we still hadn't
found the right
person and that's really sort of
nerve-wracking so it depends sometimes
you get in there the first
couple weeks you know or the
you know you kind of think you know who
it is and yeah three weeks later four
weeks yeah that's who it was but
i literally worked on something where
three three months in i mean actually it
was longer than that we didn't have
anybody it was very nerve-wracking
and so it just depends
just depends
right right i always feel like there's
one role that's
the bane of your existence yeah the band
in your existence yeah there's just
always one role yeah yeah yeah
in your experience uh
obviously maybe they don't know this or
do know their students we do have
casting contracts
uh is there anything that you feel like
you would want to add to
you know is there something that is not
there now that you would want
there in a casting contract residuals
i like it i like it
let's call it 399 and 817. i
i mean i cast the original power and
that's gone off into like eight
spin-offs or whatever
and i would love to like have it
anyway
shared in that success in a longer
longer way but let's not talk about all
that in a contract um
wow
yeah but that's a good one
that's
yeah yeah a good one yeah or bonuses
something something
where you share in the
you know the
right
uh what success
one of the students questions was if
you're trying to land a star for a lead
role
what is your approach how do you
approach that specifically differently
than
just casting a movie when you know you
have to land a star
how do you go about that
well hopefully you have a director and a
script that
will appeal
um
to that star um
wow it's a
little star
through any means necessary i mean
you know i mean that's really it's like
you call call the manager okay let me
let me call them and tell them this is
coming you know just any way you can get
something to
uh
make it rise above the rest of the
script someone's you know
someone's being sent
um
yeah that's a hard that's a hard one to
sort of
maybe the approach is
a little more delicate
yeah
because we all of a sudden
depending on the level of the director
in the script we become sales people yes
you know and we're trying to
i would say first off try to get the
agent manager to read the script
you know in hopes of having a
conversation about
yes that actor for this director yeah
yeah no we are the sales people
yeah and that's yeah
yeah
uh
when you have to work on a project where
you know you're gonna
have to look for people who have who
don't have a lot of experience
in acting you know like a lot of young
people just starting out is there
something
you look for differently
how do you handle
knowing that you're not gonna
have a cast with a lot of experience
and is that okay
one of them wanted to know
yeah i think
hopefully you look
for someone even if they're not that
experienced who
seems to
get better with each
audition they seem to like have a
natural
instinct for it they seem to
outside of what you're telling them to
do they make decisions about what to do
as that character that
make you kind of set up it's like okay
they're thinking you know they're not
just
repeating
just repeating lines or repeating
uh going down on
down an avenue that i may suggest to
them they're actually
taking their own accord and
oh they're coming up with something on
their own
right
so that's like okay well that's that's
interesting um
and hopefully i think maybe what we try
to do with inexperienced people maybe
surround them with someone who's a
little more experienced you know if you
can put someone who's uh
maybe have an actor who knows a little
bit more but around a little bit more
they can be around that person's a
little less experience it's just they
can kind of it's a good influence
on them
so i wonder was this question someone
was trying to figure out how to
how to how to make a movie
knowing that they're going to be using
inexperienced actors and how do you how
do you how do you do that
i think it was probably it might have
been from one of the acting students you
know what's it like auditioning actors
who lack experience or
you know
how do you help that
i think it was maybe yeah but i'm not
sure if it was an acting student or yeah
a directing student
i'm pretty sensitive to that in in a
room like another people inexperienced
and they don't quite know where to sit
or what or you know how to
do it or what you just try to
help them and just the the act of having
to audition
yeah
which is
yeah that's that's a learning curve
yeah and it's reminding them that so
much of acting is listening
that's it they get in the room and they
start doing
and
you know so much of film acting is
listening right the camera's on them and
they're not the ones speaking
and
it's trying to help them be grounded
enough yes to be still enough to just
listen to what is being said and
well i think something that you said to
bernie before just trying to be
just like a a kind person in the room
you know so they're not facing
you know just
so they feel like they have a little bit
of support yeah in a room we're just
trying to be there it doesn't do us any
good to like not uh
make the actors comfortable
yeah absolutely i mean so you know i
mean you know as much as i love what we
do and i know you do too
it still always surprises and amazes me
that
how this is how people get jobs they you
know
through the action of auditioning you
know because it's so filled with so much
tension hope fear yeah you know whatever
we can do to help
relax it
yeah be in that moment
and i think the repetitive nature of it
i think doing it over and over and over
and over again is going to help
inexperience actors and right it's just
something you have to do again and again
yeah
uh one more question i think from them
is
uh what is it like working with a
first-time director
you know it's it depends who the first
time director
is obviously uh
let's say it's a director right out of
school you know what i mean or yeah
and you love the script and you've
decided to cast it yeah
i got i think you have to be there sort
of
teaching a certain
well that's yeah that's that's a whole
other
that that's a whole other thing it's um
you know you're there to guide them you
know just to guide them and
hopefully say
you're just there to guide them it's
just a little bit more of a
hands-on
you know there is not necessarily a
shorthand
uh and they may not necessarily have
gone through a casting process so you
really sort of have to say no you could
you actually can talk to the actor you
can actually ask them to do it again you
cannot you know so it's really guiding
them through the whole process
of
of casting and some will have more of a
natural it's like a duck to water
they'll
they'll get into it and and and and be
and be better at it sooner than others
and
yeah you're their guide and teacher and
yeah
that reminds me did you have a mentor or
anyone that guided you through your
career or at one time in your career no
you know i've learned a lot from people
who've worked with with me i've learned
a lot from jeannie mccarthy i've learned
a lot from
directors i've worked with
from freer's
[Music]
just watching
them
watching him steven first just see
people and make decisions and just this
is i've learned a lot it's interesting
how directors come to
who they want for a role it's i've tried
to pay attention to that uh quentin i
mean just looking at him
uh freyr's is interesting because he's
just
it's it's it's amorphous sort of i
really admire him as a as a director and
as a director of actors and it's uh
i don't quite know how he does it what
he
i just try to look listen to how he
makes decisions then later i'll ask him
but okay okay is this interesting coming
someone some come from like a feeling
from uh
it's just it's just i've never watched
from the directors i've worked with yeah
sure
do you have a
won't call it a favor but is there a
movie in your
repertoire that you've worked on
that
was just the experience of casting that
movie was special for
such and such reason
whether it was an actor director you
know what i mean it's not about
favorites like yeah give a little tell
us about a specific story of a film that
just to this day you still
remember love i think ed wood was a
really
just great from start to finish
uh
i mean i was working with tim burton
who's
oh my god i forgot you did that movie
it was about sort of la it was set in la
it was
just as a production just a pleasure to
work on
uh great people who you know sarah
jessica hadn't
done a million things and
all these people that were in it playing
small parts
and it was just a really great um
that was a really fun experience and
once upon a time in hollywood that felt
very personal i took very very personal
because
all those small parts in hollywood were
so
amazing
it was like
you just kept wanting to go oh my god
who was that oh my god that was her
i remember watching that it was like oh
it's so good and just said it was said
and you know i would go see movies up on
hollywood boulevard when i was growing
up it was just and i remember reading
about those murders and my kitchen table
with my mom and my dad it was just and
the cultural references within the movie
you know the tv shows within it so
anyway so that was that was also
something sort of personal even though i
didn't know those people i didn't you
know
uh that that was great that was great
wow
all right i have a last question for you
uh
[Music]
if you were starting all over again
casting from like the day one is there
something you wish
you knew that you don't know
or that you would do differently
i wish i knew
that i was pretty good at it
at an earlier
time and not been
insecure
because the way i started i
was actually hiring people to assist me
who had more experience than i did
and i felt a little guilty about that
and
uh i wish i'd just
not felt that insecurity and trusted
that
i was pretty good at it and
don't
don't beat yourself up right
that's beautiful actually
uh
there's i still feel like there's so
much we can learn you know i mean that's
what i love about the job too because
we're always
learning
yeah if it's just learning a new actor
yeah it reminds me that oh yeah i do
have to keep learning yeah i don't feel
like i know it all i don't you know i
don't feel that way
at all
you know and i feel like i have to be
reminded to have to
just remind myself that you know
yeah there's also there's always
something new to learn and yeah
yeah
and any final advice you'd
give to our students who want to go into
who want to be a casting director or
want to be an actor or director let's
say just you know
have faith
know your craft
um
always
just
always feed yourself just feed yourself
um
you know like i said with film history
but also just live life um
and
observe life and just
travel outside of your
your little circle and
um
experience the world as much as you can
and use that experience
in whatever craft you choose
that's beautiful
thank you vicky oh my god it was so
great to get to hear your story and how
you started in this business and uh this
was so nice i feel like i know you a
different way now uh so thank you
hope it was helpful or enlightening in
some sort of one
and i want to thank all of our students
for participating in the academy
visiting arts film series filmmade
edition for casting directors
you